schon seit ich mein erstes tattoo hat
frage ich mich wie schwer es eigentlich
ist selber zu tätowieren genau deswegen
möchte ich mit euch zusammen probieren
in sieben tagen titulieren
[Musik]
grundsätzlich kommen wir das konzept vom
tätowieren gar nicht so schwierig vor
also man hat hintemann hat eine nadel
und man sticht das unter die haut ich
glaube allerdings trotzdem dass es so
einige tücken und schwierigkeiten mit
sich bringt aber genau das wollen wir
zusammen heraus ich habe bevor ich das
hier angefangen habe schon mit einem
kumpel gesprochen der sich ein bisschen
besser auskennt und der hat mir davon
abgeraten eine günstige tätowiermaschine
zu kaufen teure maschinen bekommt
allerdings auch nicht in frage weil ich
das geld dazu nicht hat und nicht weiß
ob mir das spaß macht und mich da
dranbleiben und deswegen werden wir
damit anfangen alles zu handpuppen das
bedeutet man eine nadel in der hand und
die sticht man jedes mal einzeln unter
die haut also im prinzip ist das einzige
was wir brauchen eine menge nadeln dann
die farbe natürlich und irgendwas wo wir
die farbe rein tun können also kleine
beherrschen und ich hab noch synthetik
aufgestellt damit ich das nicht direkt
auf meiner haut ausprobieren muss ja
außerdem noch ein paar kleinigkeiten wie
handschuhe desinfektionsmittel
papiertücher und zum kram den man aber
meistens irgendwie rumfliegen hatte und
im prinzip ist das schon wir können
anfangen die motive zu zeichnen und dann
vielleicht sogar schon zu probieren
also ich habe jetzt noch weiche linie
geholt ich habe keine ahnung warum aber
als ich könnte mir gut an hier immer so
war selina auch die haut gemacht scheint
richtig zu sein so ja grundsätzlich
bitte nehmt das hier nicht als anleitung
euch selber zu tätowieren ich habe
absolut keine ahnung und ich probiere es
einfach aus tätowierer kosten meistens
ein bisschen mehr geld sind aber ihr
geld wert also wenn ihr vorhabt euch
irgendwas zu machen dann geht so
jemanden lasst euch beraten und schaut
euch das hier nicht an weil ihr das
nachmacht bitte nicht vermutlich mache
ich jetzt viele falsch aber ich möchte
einfach starten deswegen probiere ich
jetzt einfach ein paar linien smiley
irgendwas auf diese synthetik
auszuzeichnen so das sind meine
allerersten drei versuche irgendwas zu
tätowieren ich bin eigentlich recht
zufrieden damit wie es funktioniert hat
ich finde das sieht schon ganz okay aus
die haut kann ich aber nicht empfehlen
ich habe das gefühl dass man überhaupt
nicht einschätzen kann wie tief man
stechen muss und ich habe das gefühl
dass die haut sich einfach nicht verhält
wie echte haut die nur deswegen staat
hingegen
das morgen schon damit jeden tag echte
haut zu tätowieren und dann jeden tag
ein tattoo zu machen und zu gucken wie
sehr ich mich verbessern kann viel mehr
gehabt auf morgen viel spaß bei euch
geht es direkt weiter so tag nummer zwei
ich konnte mittlerweile herausfinden
dass unter dem fuß eine perfekte stelle
ist um das tätowieren zu üben weil da
geht das tattoo irgendwann wieder weg
weil man das abläuft quasi was es genau
sein wird weiß ich noch nicht ich
sketche jetzt mal ein bisschen
rumprobieren ein cooles motiv zu finden
blitze kleines problem an der sache ist
dass sich nicht besonders begabt bin was
zeichnen angeht aber irgendwas wer die
show findet hier noch so transfer papier
das ist dafür da damit man zeichnen kann
und die zeichnung dann auf die haut
übertragen kann
scheißegal wir malen jetzt also
grundsätzlich möchte ich gerne tattoos
haben die clean sind ich will keine
schattierungen ich will eigentlich keine
gefühlte flächen ich will eigentlich nur
linien oder irgendwas geschrieben ist
oder irgendwie so im prinzip ist es auch
scheißegal weil es eher darum geht dass
ich lernen möchte zu tätowieren und
nicht was ich tue mir aber sehr
grundsätzlich schon irgendwas gutes zu
haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was
[Musik]
und wer nicht zu schwer zu machen weil
beim aller ersten dazu habe ich mich
jetzt dafür entschieden wirklich ein
pfeil zu machen weil das eben nur drei
linien sind glauben solchen sachen hilft
ist immer ganz viele verschiedene sachen
zu machen weil man sich dann besser
entscheiden kann mehr
entscheidungsmöglichkeiten fast
anderthalb monaten barfuß lauf habe ich
mich doch dazu entschieden das nicht
unter meinen fuß zu machen weil ich
glaube dass wir sofort weg
ich mache es jetzt an die seite von
meinem fuß also hier hin da kann ich das
verstecken wenn ich das verstecken will
und kann zeigen wir nicht zeigen ich
würde raten das nicht draußen zu machen
hier fliegt übers viel staub und übelst
viel scheiße um ich werde das zwar alles
desinfizieren aber hier ist trotzdem so
viel kram unterwegs dass es immer besser
ist das drin zu machen
perfekt ist es nicht aber ich glaube das
reicht als anhaltspunkt und so weiß ich
wo ich tätowieren muss und wo außerdem
konnte ich herausfinden wofür die weiße
linie ist das einfach damit die nadel
besser einbringen kann und man die hand
besser ziehen sind über die raute und so
ein allgemein damit den unterricht
neidiger wird man könnte schon fast
meinen dass sich der typ profi und weil
es heute an die richtige haut geht
dachte ich probiere das heute mal so
steril zu halten es geht auch wenn wir
uns draußen befinden und hier eh nicht
störend ist noch ein tipp tattoo farben
muss immer gut geschüttelt werden
das jugend inhaltsstoff drin sind die
nur gespielt ich habe keine ahnung was
ich hier mache bitte macht das nicht
nach ich tippe ich würde natürlich
niemals vergessen machen so ganz kurz
einwand hier bevor es am zweiten tour
geht wenn ich das video bis hierhin
gefällt lass mir gerne ein leichter oder
schreibt in die kommentare was sich
sonst noch so in sieben tagen testen
kann außerdem will ich mich freuen wenn
ihr meinen instinkt da könnt ihr schon
kleinen spoiler sehen von den fertigen
tattoos da ist genau gerade ein bild
online gegangen aber jetzt viel spaß mit
dem zweiten tour und dem rest des videos
[Musik]
ist genauso an wie jedes mal wenn ich
tituliert wurde probiere jetzt einfach
hier so genau wie es diese linie
nachzuzeichnen und dann hoffen wir mal
dass irgendwas dass wir das erste mal
dass die überschüssige farbe abwischen
jetzt werden wir sehen ob überhaupt
irgendwas unter der haut geblieben ist
oder ob das alles also bis hierhin habe
ich jetzt tätowiert und das hat jetzt 13
minuten gedauert da zehn mal rein oder
nicht rein gestoppten leicht nicht ob
die farbe der jetzt so drin bleibt oder
so
ok ich probiere erstmal ein bisschen
weiter zu machen und dann schauen
[Musik]
wenn die linie jetzt wirklich so bleibt
wie die jetzt gerade aussieht war es
viel viel weniger anspruchsvoll als ich
mir vorgestellt hätte
also ich dachte vielleicht bleibt jetzt
die farbe nicht unter der haut oder ich
hab's nicht die linie gerade zu machen
so wie es jetzt aussieht ist die linie
gerade die farbe bleibt unter der haut
und dich tätowiere seit zwei minuten
oder anscheinend wirklich kein hexenwerk
aber ich sehe trotzdem schon an meiner
linie und an allem das ist dann
natürlich verbesserungsmöglichkeiten ich
war jetzt erst mal das tattoo fertig und
dann schauen uns das ganze zum schluss
einmal an so kurze planänderungen man
erkennt schon die feinen linien des
pfeils gar nicht mehr so richtig das
bedeutet dass vielleicht doch nicht so
einfach wie ich gedacht habe auch besser
so weil sonst hätte dieses projekt
überhaupt keinen sinn
auf jeden fall könnt ihr hier sehen dass
die beiden oberen linien des feilen also
diese und diese nicht so super fein sind
da wo sie zusammen lauf deswegen habe
ich mich jetzt kurzfristig dazu
entschieden den oben doch auszufüllen
und das vielleicht so noch zur welt so
für den ersten tag und das erste tattoo
bin ich auf jeden fall extrem zufrieden
ich habe aber auch relativ schnell
gemerkt dass es vielleicht doch nicht so
einfach ist wie gedacht das ist auch gut
so weil sonst würde dieses projekt hier
keinen sinn mehr machen erholt ich denke
dass jetzt abdullah salbe drauf und dann
sehen wir morgen wie es morgen aussieht
und kümmern uns morgen um das leute so
tag nummer 3 bevor ich euch zeigen was
aus dem tattoo von gestern geworden ist
müssen wir erstmal das motiv für das
heutige zeit zu finden ich glaube heute
machen wir aber nicht alles auf dem
papier sondern probieren mal in
photoshop und ein bisschen auf dem ipad
herum irgendwas digital zu machen das zu
drucken und dann aus transrapid außerdem
würde ich heute ganz gerne irgendwas ein
bisschen anspruchsvolleres ausprobieren
wo ich mir vielleicht auch ein bisschen
mehr zeigen
[Musik]
okay ich hab mich jetzt für so ein
create entschieden damit ich mich selber
daran erinnern öfter mal irgend etwas
produktives zu machen und irgendwas zu
erschaffen weil das ja eigentlich das
was mir am meisten spaß macht um aber
noch einen kleinen frist reinzubekommen
habe ich das eher spiegelverkehrt
gemacht weiß nicht dass sie ziemlich
cool aus ziemlich klein superklein also
super feine linien und das werde ich
jetzt machen bevor ich damit allerdings
anfangen müssen wir natürlich gucken was
aus dem tattoo von gestern geworden
für mein allererstes tattoo nicht damit
auf jeden fall zufrieden allerdings
sieht man natürlich an vielen stellen
dass das verbesserungswürdig ist ich
habe überlegt dass ich das jetzt am ende
der woche probiere noch mal auszubessern
und hoffentlich in der zeit noch mal ein
bisschen mehr gelernt habe und dann kann
ich da vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
was rausholen grundsätzlich muss ich
sagen dass ich aber ziemlich überrascht
wie gut das doch funktioniert hat das
ist jetzt nicht 100 prozent ist beim
ersten versuch ist natürlich klar umso
mehr freue ich mich jetzt auf mein
zweites der tu und ich würde ganz gerne
keine zeit mehr verlieren und einfach
starten ich habe mich bei diesem tattoo
jetzt dafür entschieden das auf meinen
beinen zu machen weil ich das super gut
erreichen kann und dass wieder eine
stelle ist bei der ich das abdecken kann
wenn ich will und freilassen kann oder
zeigen kann wenn ich das möchte jetzt
aber haare sind müssen die als
allererste kassieren weil sonst drücken
wir die da rein und das ist scheiße ich
deswegen basieren das würde doch jetzt
das transfer papier und das motiv drauf
zu machen wenn ich sitze weil dann ist
man in beiden gespannt dadurch dass das
geknickte und für gewöhnlich stehe ich
ja ganz normal so deswegen müssen wir
das motiv und das transfer papier auch
genauso aufbringen damit das tattoo eben
nicht verzogen ist also ich muss
wirklich sagen ich bin nicht weniger
aufgeregt als gestern weil es jetzt halt
irgendwie ein aufwändiger des motives
und es mehr darauf ankommt dass es fein
ist aber ich bin guter dinge ich habe
mega rock und natürlich ist es genau wie
gestern wieder nicht vernünftig
übertragen weil
[Musik]
dazwischen stand also ich bin jetzt
mittlerweile bei angekommen man sieht
wahrscheinlich schon sehr extrem dass
die linie super unterschiedlich dicke
ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau wie ich
das kontrollieren soll und das c sieht
auch ziemlich scheiße aus also der erste
buchstabe den ich gemacht habe ich mache
jetzt erstmals komplette wort durch und
schaue dann im guten mittelpunkt an
linien dicke zu finden und das noch zu
wissen
[Musik]
so sieht mein zweites ich bin eigentlich
super zufrieden auch wenn natürlich
wieder die eine oder andere stelle nicht
so geworden ist wie gedacht ich merke
aber schon dass ich viel viel sicherer
dabei werde und es macht auf jeden fall
mega spaß ich bin super gespannt was die
nächsten tage noch so bringen im
nächsten video werde ich dann anfangen
andere leute zu tätowieren und nicht
mehr bei mir auf der haut weil ich habe
gemerkt dass das über kopf manchmal ein
bisschen krieg die wir ich bin super
gespannt weil es nochmal so eins der
bürgerlich eben leute irgendwas für die
ewigkeit unter ihrer haut tätowieren und
das nicht bei mir ist und vielleicht